okay yeah this then leads into a nice
interesting point that it'll be about
last thing that we look at tonight okay
which is you can see for some functions
for instance this one right no matter
what inputs you put into this no matter
what inputs you try you can try any
numbers you like there gonna be some
outputs that are impossible to get can I
say that again no matter what inputs you
couldn't get no matter what values of X
there are some values of Y some outputs
that you will never ever ever get you
can try as hard as you like you'll never
get okay for instance I happen to know
that the number y equals negative six
you'll never get there right you can try
every single value of x that you want
and you'll never get to know 6 or
negative 7 or negative 8 how do I do
that because I have magic powers right
think about it you have all the tools
you need it's all in the graph itself
right ah
this is a quadratic it's a parabola I
chose that on purpose right um where's
the vertex of this problem where's the
lowest spot it's gonna be a well x
equals 0 and y equals negative 5 right
it'll be there it's that intercept as it
happened okay now because that's the
vertex right it's going up in this
direction it's going up in that
direction it's never gonna go below
negative 5 right another way would say
this is there's some restrictions on the
outputs okay I have a um I have a juice
maker at home okay and it's a really
great thing and you put all these things
out of it into it but guess what you're
only ever gonna get juice out of it ok
it's never gonna be able to bake a cake
you can put in all the flour and water
and eggs you like it's just gonna make
flour and water and egg juice okay not
very pleasant ok you can put in a whole
bunch of different inputs but you'll
only get seven outputs
right at the same time now have a look
at this second one this baby here this
sample and now it's not a function bomb
so many others strength from it there
are certain inputs that don't work you
put them in you try and evaluate them
and the machine breaks down right if you
go back to my Jewish McDuck right if you
put in flour it's actually gonna break
down right
it'll just say forget it I'm not even
gonna bother okay and it'll like start
putting on some work and all that kind
of thing certain puts make it break for
instance if I said this was x squared
plus y squared equals 1 that's the
familiar unit circle right value like x
equals two x equals two it's gonna break
my circle can you see why why is it
going to break this up
where is where is the unit circle this
is one one negative one one right and x
equals two is over here okay no we're on
the circle can X equal to if I want to
think about it in terms of my trying to
put it in and it become two squared plus
y squared equals one what would I do
next to simplify this a little bit I
subtract two from both sides yeah Y
squared equals negative one but there
are no numbers that we know about that
you can square and get a negative okay
so therefore out of this new way of
notation right we get this new idea
called domain and range let me give you
a definition for this okay doneita range
is all about well if some inputs break
our function right and if some outputs
are impossible with my function then I
want to know what works I wonder what is
possible okay so domain simply means
what X values can I put you right
because some work and some don't
as you'll see in a bit and range means
what Y values can I get out
because sometimes no matter what you put
in it's impossible to get out certain
about it okay so let's just quickly do
eg I will do debate this and then we'll
move on to arrange by the way if you're
trying to work out which ones which you
can think about it this way domain and
range D and alphabetical just like mixes
and Y's or if you like and she said oh I
remember what domain is because debate
is like door like pizza dough and people
make pizza dough by stretching it out
this way like if you stretch it out this
way you're some kind of reader right so
domain goes wide which is X's take it or
leave it okay
ah now let's think about some functions
right let's go with this guy once this
guy is enable what's he called starts
with an H right now you can quickly see
right there are some values of X I could
put in few big gray but there are some
values that break the rules of the
universe right before we say what the
values are quickly what's this see what
buddy how would you describe it
very good first and third quadrants here
in here right and you're getting this
curvy shape uh she is that part and then
there's that part okay now there's a
couple of things I'm missing off of this
graph right what do I need to put on
here extra features yeah the asymptotes
right the dotted lines okay now I'm
gonna put one in first this guy the
equation of this asymptote is x equals
zero right that's where the asymptote is
but what that implies is that the
function microphone over X it can't go
there right cuz you put in x equals zero
and what happens to Y it just blows up
one over zero actually it's not zero
it's not infinity it's undefined if you
like I can give you a long argument for
why it's undefined why it can't be
defined but suffice to say it isn't okay
so therefore x equals zero doesn't work
it's not an x value I could put in right
if you're less than zero you're okay if
you're greater than zero
you're also okay but if you're at zero
you're in trouble okay so I would say
for this graph the domain I'm just going
to from now on I'm not a writer to work
just abbreviate the domain is yeah mark
this it's X is less than zero or X is
greater than zero that's the domain okay
that's the way I would write it as well
gonna borrow this language from
inequalities that we've seen before
okay let me tell you a way not to write
it away not to write it X can't equal 0
now that's a true statement X can't
equal 0 but it doesn't answer the
question because look what was the
definition we just slapped on this thing
what X values can I put it and you say
an x value that you can't put it okay
it'll be a little bit like um I don't
know if any of you are familiar this is
this um if you ask me my favorite food
is right you ask me what my favorite
food is and I say well um I hate diría
now if any of you know what girion is
right your enemy's a fruit that's
created the tropics and it's a large
troops about the size of my head so it's
a big thing but more importantly ok
firstly it's covered it's very very
heavy it's like it's like a watermelon
in mass ok in size but it's covered in
spikes right it's growing on a tree if
it fell down from a tree and you're
underneath it it would kill you right
like it's that heavy and that spiky and
not only that but it smells like it has
killed someone
it smells like something died ok now
some people go figure they love this
food ok if you're one of these I'm sorry
all right
I hate it ok now if you ask me what's
your favorite food and I say I hate
durian I haven't answered the question
right I haven't answered the question
domaine says what can I put in what's
going to work and if you say X is not
equal to zero you are telling me the
opposite thing you're telling me what
doesn't work it's not the answer does
that make sense
ok so therefore um don't do that I'm
gonna rub that off so you see
it's just zero what is his grave easier
that's the whales